yeah johnny depp who is of course one of
hollywood's most successful actors but
this is arguably the most important
performance of his life it's certainly
the most financially significant with
150 million dollars of damages on the
line he's been on the stand now jonathan
for about an hour it's been an
incredibly animated performance he's
spoken slowly and deliberately under the
steely stare of his former wife amber
heard just as a reminder and she
he rather is suing her for 50 million
dollars in damages
this case centering around a 2018
article that she wrote in the washington
post newspaper in which she says she is
a survivor of domestic abuse she doesn't
mention johnny depp by name but he says
it was plainly about him he began his
testimony this afternoon by accusing
amber heard
of lying he said it's been six years of
trying times much of his first hour of
testimony on the stand has centered upon
him recalling the dynamic between his
own mum and dad he said his mum betty
sue was the physical emotional and
psychological abuser in their family he
said if i got in trouble at school the
first thing mum would say was john take
him out there he gets the belt so he'd
take me out to the garage johnny depp
said to the jury and i'll never forget
this white thick leather belt that he
would take off and he would inflict
punishment he's just begun speaking
about the early stages of his
relationship with amber heard he said
for the first year year and a half of
our relationship it was amazing there
were a couple of things that stuck in my
head that i thought might be a dilemma
at some point i expect it in the next
couple of hours when he's on the stand
he will elaborate upon that but i think
we can bring you a line from the early
part of johnny depp's testimony where he
accused amber heard of lying about him
being abusive he invoked some of the
most famous fairy tales to make this
point
it's been six years of
trying times
it's very
strange when
one day your
[Music]
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds your
quasimodo
and
i
i
i didn't
deserve that nor did my
children
so johnny depp on the stand at the
moment we expect his testimony to last
into tomorrow morning where he'll
undergo cross-examination
this trial is expected to last
another six weeks johnny depp suing
amber heard his former wife for 50
million dollars she in turn is
counter-suing him for 100 million
dollars i think what we can all agree on
is that it's an incredibly unedifying
spectacle as both of those people relive
the darkest chapters of their lives
together
okay martha thank you for following that
update from martha let's listen in to
the actor as he continues giving
evidence in virginia he's talking about
the movie franchise pirates of the
caribbean all or
whatever
um
so yes more security and you know then
just getting followed
you know by hordes of paparazzi and
things like that it's it's it's uh
i've had worse jobs certainly i can't
complain about it
but um
yeah
uh
after a while you realize that
uh
um anonymity
uh has left the building
a long time ago you know the anonymity's
gone um
and that's it that's an odd thing to
deal with
um
when you just
i mean you can't just drive down to the
diner and get a cup of coffee or
something it's not possible it turns
into something else altogether
so it's
you know
it's acceptance and of course there's a
bit of sacrifice
involved i i i can't complain
about the uh
work
that i've been given
i can't complain about any of that um i
have no right to
um but
it does make you have to think very
creatively
with
when you've got little kids about how to
take them to the park
or you know to the swings or to this or
that or movie or you know
it becomes uh it becomes a strategic
mission
and and
and that's what happened after pirates